SPEAKER: As a
developer, you want
to quickly deliver
great cloud applications
like web apps, mobile
APIs, and background jobs.
But choosing a cloud solution
often comes with trade-offs.
On the one hand, you can
choose to manage your servers.
But this can mean provisioning
and configuring them
yourself, plus worrying about
scaling as traffic patterns
change.
And you might run the risk
of overprovisioning resources
and paying for more
than what you need.
On the other hand, you can
pick a traditional serverless
solution.
But this can limit the
languages and libraries
you can use and may
require code changes
and make it harder to
move your application.
What if you didn't have
to make that choice
and could enjoy the
best of both worlds?
Introducing Cloud Run--
bringing server agility
to your containerized apps.
You can use Cloud Run to deploy
any stateless HTTP container.
This lets you write your code
in your favorite language
with the framework or binary
library that works for you.
Then simply specify the
language, your dependencies,
and your start script
in a Dockerfile
and, with one command,
package it up into a container
and boom, you're good to go.
Your app is now deployed
and running in the cloud.
You can forget about
provisioning or managing
servers.
Cloud Run does that for you.
Cloud Run automatically
and quickly scales
up or down based on
your incoming traffic
and even scales down to zero.
And you pay only for the
resources that your app uses,
billed down to the nearest
one hundredth millisecond.
And because Cloud Run
is built with Knative,
you can use it with your own
Kubernetes engine cluster too.
With Cloud Run on GKE,
you can build and deploy
apps to your own
Kubernetes cluster
with the same easy
experience and benefits.
So the next time you want to
build a great app quickly,
check out Cloud Run.
Get started today.